première cotation de l'action paribas
480 francs aujourd'hui à la bourse de
paris
réactions embarrassées à droite après la
proposition de valérie giscard d'estaing
et hier sur antenne 2 d'un référendum
sur la réduction de 7 à 5 ans du mandat
présidentiel révélations sur le mystère
du cadavre découvert il ya plus de deux
mois poids de montélimar les enquêteurs
sur une piste syrienne
aujourd'hui jeudi 12 février 1987
nouvelle journée de détention pour les
otages français du liban
marcel fontaine marcel carton jean paul
kauffmann jean louis normandin antenne 2
n'ont toujours pas été libérés
bonsoir l'action paribas a été coté à
480 font aujourd'hui à la bourse de
paris la compagnie financière effectué
sa rentrée à la bourse à la corbeille
cinq années après avoir été
nationalisées on guettait en se frottant
les mains à l'avance la cotation en
sachant que le prix unitaire vendue par
l'état de l'action paribas fut de 405
francs et que plus de trois millions et
demi de français s'étaient portés
acquéreurs sur cette première cotation
de paribas reportage dans le berre jean
louis goût sert une rentrée en fanfare
pour paribas à la bourse de paris cinq
ans après sa nationalisation
les acheteurs nombreux se bousculaient
face à de rares vendeurs
il y avait deux millions cinq cent mille
ordres d'achat pour seulement deux cent
cinquante mille vendeurs l'action
paribas étant coté sur le marché du
contente
le dépouillement les orgues n'a pas
donné lieu aux débordements traditionnel
de la criée entre les acheteurs et les
vendeurs le déséquilibre était si
important que la jante chance qui cotent
l'action paris marc la charte nivard
flornoy décidé de diviser le nombre d
achat par l'iss
en clair si vous étiez acheteurs de sang
paribas vous n'en avez eu que 10 à 480
francs grâce à cette réduction la
cotation était possible à la grande
satisfaction du pdg paribas
c'est bien passé j'aime surtout
satisfait de voir que premier jour de la
cotation à trouver un accord équilibré
servir à bâté marché dans quelques
semaines l'action paribas rejoindra
certainement si grande soeur à la
corbeille au marché règlement mensuel
pour la déclaration des revenus 86 le
miz de l'économie accorde un petit
sursis la date limite est reporté du 28
février au 4 mars et le ministère de
l'économie vient d'autre part d'indiquer
qu' une réduction des prix du gaz
domestique était en vigueur à compter
d'aujourd'hui réduction de 3 2% démenti
du gouvernement il n'y a aucune étude de
conventions aménageant les conditions de
vente de tf dans la perspective de la
privatisation de la première chaîne de
télévision il faut cependant noter qu'un
arrangement serait en préparation entre
le seul repreneur déclaré pour l'instant
c'est à dire la société bouygues et les
salariés de tf1 se serait ainsi un
montage très original explications avec
karen busqué robert rosier les salariés
de tf1 veulent être dans la course
leur but obtenir 50 des impôts 100 du
capital de la chaîne
l'opération se ferait en deux temps un
ventes de la chaîne aux investisseurs
50% notamment francis bruit au personnel
10% au public 40% deuxième temps des
opérations complexes de rachat aurait
lieu entre les porteurs d'actions
elle aboutirait à un contrôle de la
majorité par le personnel dans six mois
environ
bouygues gardant 49,9 pour cent
deux questions restent en suspens
premièrement pour acheter leur part
majoritaire les salariés constituerait
une société holding elle emprunterait
auprès des banques
mais les banques jouerait le jeu la
somme est colossale c'est pourquoi les
salariés s'appuierait sur une loi de
1984 favorisant le rachat d'entreprise
par les salariés
grâce à cette loi une mise de fonds
minimum permet d'emprunter beaucoup
d'argent alors deuxième problème cette
mise de fonds cet apport personnel
indispensable saura-t-il réunis par les
salariés il faut trouver 370 millions de
francs soit 15 à 100 mille francs par
salarié volontaire une majorité y est
favorable
je suis plutôt pour je suis pas à mettre
des billes de dents jusqu'à jusqu'à
combien bas seront des mini biya je vais
te dire mon mini salaires c'est certain
qu'avec l'arrivée de quelqu'un d'aussi
de six ford si costaud sur le plan
financier que bouygues
ça devient parfaitement crédible alors
si bohic jouent le jeu et si la holding
peut fonctionner grâce à son apport
d'argent mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord pour moi même participé à ce
projet j'aimerais pouvoir le faire mais
je ne peux pas financièrement
pécuniairement parlant je suis pas
capable de le faire
les autres conditions à remplir
n'inquiète pas les salariés tf1 se
soumettent aux critères du mieux disant
culturel
nous sommes les mieux placés estimé
professionnels de la une et puis
l'implication du personnel dans le
capital est un gage de cohésion de
succès ajoutons rue cognacq-jay où l'on
a le moral
mais c'est à la cncl de trancher
au ministère de l'éducation en fin
d'après midi rencontre rené monory
dirigeants de la fédération d'éducation
nationale la fen au lendemain de la
manifestation des instituteurs contre le
projet d'émettre directeur la délégation
syndicale souhaitait que l'on réexamine
le décret et que l'on négocié mais aucun
accord n'a été conclu comme le rapporte
maintenant rené monory est tout d'abord
jean claude barbat rang de secrétaire
général du snu pour la rencontre la
ministre qui a affirmé de la manière la
plus claire qu'il était déterminé à ne
rien modifier il
ce décret est signé il a été signée at
il ajouté par le premier ministre et il
a été approuvé par l'unanimité du
conseil des ministres en conséquence de
toi il faut aussi dire qu'il veut pas
revenir dessus
en tout état de cause pour nous le
problème est clair la détermination dont
a fait preuve hier elle existe on rendra
compte de cette réponse du ministre a au
personnel que nous représentons nous
sommes déjà certains de la réponse
l'action continuer à se durcir
il était pas question que je retire le
décret d'abord il avait été pris au mois
de décembre le décret principal signé
par le président de la république faut
pas l'oublier et que personne ne peut
contester l'autorité du président de la
république et que d'autre part il ya
tout même dans le budget des moyens
supplémentaires que je compte bien
mettre en oeuvre pour la rentrée
prochaine
alors il reste que l'on peut discuter
certaines circulaires d'application ce
que j'ai peu promis de faire cela dit
contre toute une profession comme vous
le dites il ya effectivement beaucoup
d'instituteurs qui se rencontrent et
puis on a aussi beaucoup qui m'écrivent
qui sont pour
donc la proportion ne la connaîtra
jamais ils disent que la mobilisation
reste forte et que l'on retour des
vacances ce sera de nouveau la grève
savez on verra bien en plus le sni a dit
qu' il essaierait de s'opposer à
l'application du décret je laisse la
responsabilité hosted cette déclaration
car vous savez dans la république moi
j'ai toujours respecté les majorités
leur décision et dire qu'un syndicat ne
respectera pas les décisions d'un
gouvernement issu du peuple c'est en mai
une responsabilité importante qu'est ce
que vous ferez s'il décide et à
l'appliquer et bien moi je vous donne
rendez vous nous verrez qui sera
appliquée et vous verrez sans doute
qu'on aura peut-être plus de candidats
que de postes qui seront mieux
concours l'ancien président de la
république valéry giscard d'estaing a
quelque peu modifié hier soir sur
antenne 2 dans l'heure de vérité les
règles du jeu politique actuel monsieur
giscard d'estaing s'est écarté
volontairement la course à l'elysée en
répondant à la question taboue de sa
candidature j'ai déjà services et à
d'autres de servir à leur tour et je
souhaite qu'il réussisse
je ne suis pas candidat à l'élection
présidentielle ayant ainsi régler le
problème évoqué ici par gus l'ancien
chef de l'état s'est déclaré favorable à
l'organisation d'un référendum sur la
réduction du mandat présidentiel de sept
à cinq ans dès le printemps prochain
je souhaite que le gouvernement ne
propose que je crois qu'il est jamais
bon dans un pays que le gouvernement
soit en retard sur une évolution que
l'opinion souhaite donc je souhaite que
soit le gouvernement c'est le
gouvernement le fait de déposer un
projet ce projet est voté par les deux
assemblées est soumis à référendum
soumis à référendum quand d'un
réfléchissiez je crois qu'il faut
déconnecter cette affaire autant que
possible de l'élection présidentielle or
l'élection présidentielle et les bus
pour le printemps 88 le town prochain
vous aurez les congrès des partis sortis
demande du parti socialiste du rpr ils
vont choisir leur candidat ou l'annoncé
donc à référendum sera dans le début de
la campagne électorale ça n'est pas
souhaitable et le bon moment nos maux
souhaitable c'est le printemps prochain
ce qui fait que je pense qu'il est
souhaitable de le faire à ce moment-là
si le gouvernement ne le propose pas
profitant du droit d'initiative des
parlementaires et avec d'autres je le
proposerai après cette proposition de
monsieur giscard d'estaing les réactions
enregistrées dans les différents partis
de la majorité gouvernementale n'ont pas
été unanime les barriste comme françois
d'aubert ou pascal clément soulignant
qu'à vouloir raccourcir le mandat
présidentiel à cinq ans on pouvait
arriver à l'objectif opposé c'est à dire
au piège du double monde
jean claude gaudin sur france inter ne
se déclarait pas favorable un tel
référendum
côté gaulliste michel debré comme claude
labbé réaffirmait son attachement à la
constitution de 58 et au septennat
je suis tout à fait favorable au
maintien du septennat pour deux
premières raisons très simples et plus
pour des considérations plus importante
une raison très simple pourquoi admirez
la tradition chez les autres et quand
elle est valable ne pas la respecter
chez soi une autre raison très simple
nous considérons qu'il faut six ans pour
un bon maire qu'il faut six ans pour un
bon conseiller général s'étant pour un
président de la république
c'est bien le moins assez première
considération il s'en ajoutent deux
autres qui sont à mon sens capitale la
première nous vivons dans un monde où
les démocraties ont à faire face à des
régimes totalitaires qui sont gouvernés
par des dictateurs ou par les tyrans
dont le pouvoir s'étend sur de longues
années il faut être gouvernés et la
capacité de gouverner comprend une
certaine durée du mandat présidentiel
en outre la france comme bien des
démocraties est animé par des partis il
faut éviter le régime des partis et il
faut aider le président de la république
qui par aide et sans sera souvent un
homme de parti à sortir de lui-même à
savoir prendre des responsabilités au
niveau de l'état
la durée du mandat est un élément
capital à cet égard voilà les deux
considérations essentielles et
j'ajouterais que parmi les problèmes qui
sont ceux des français et de la france
aujourd'hui il en étant l'autre que de
soulever celui là pareil je vous dis
comme je le pense dérisoire le
porte-parole du premier ministre
monsieur denis beaudoin en rappelant que
l'impératif absolu était que la majorité
reste yoni ne se déchirent pas a indiqué
que jacques chirac s'entretiendrait de
façon informelle avec les principaux
responsables de sa majorité il est vrai
sans lui le seigle que les propos de
monsieur giscard d'estaing sur la
réduction du mandat présidentiel
créé pour le moins de l'embarras valéry
giscard d'estaing à l'art est il à la
manière pour jouer au billard politique
en utilisant les quatre dande premières
bandes premier choc je ne suis plus
candidat à l'elysée
aussitôt il se situe au-dessus de tout
mêler histoire sans doute de rafler
quelques points dans les sondages tant
il est vrai qu'en france on apprécie par
les candidats et qu'on se met à vénérer
ce qu'ils ne sont plus au dessus de la
mêlée encore deuxième bande jusqu'à
confirme qu'il se place au niveau
européen
candidat à la présidence
l'europe oui bien sûr pourquoi pas un
honneur au dessus de la mêlée pensez
vous car immédiatement relais régis car
destin se sert de la troisième bande
je suis candidat à la présidence de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'assemblée nationale
un coup contre bernard stasi le looser
de la dernière partie un coup contre le
cds donc contre les barriste mais la 4e
bande est la plus délicate
la réduction du mandat présidentiel la
giscard mais tous ses partenaires mal à
l'aise le gouvernement parce que chirac
l'a dit ce n'est pas une réforme de
première nécessité le rpr parce qu'ils
se divisent entre pompidolien et
gaullistes d'historique
vous venez d'entendre michel debré et
surtout l'udf parce que raymond barre
encore lui se veut aujourd'hui le
gardien de l'orthodoxie gaulliste face
aux supporters du mandat à cinq ans
finalement valéry giscard d'estaing a
beau avoir gagné la première manche il
hier soir tout en finesse est ce être
immédiatement mis hors jeu
il n'empêche il peut encore influer sur
la revanche est sur la même faute a
ajouté jean-louis que bernard stasi fera
connaître sa position ce soir sur son
maintien ou son retrait de la
candidature à la présidence de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'assemblée nationale
et puis que les observateurs politiques
attendent beaucoup du dîner de demain
soir entre raymond barre et françois
léotard en provence obsèques ce matin de
michel baroin le patron de la gmf la
garantie mutuelle des fonctionnaires
mort dans un accident d'avion le 5
février dernier au cameroun aux obsèques
de michel baroin
le très nombreuses personnalités
politiques le premier ministre jacques
chirac alain plouër jacques chaban
delmas plusieurs ministres du
gouvernement
des conseillers du président mitterrand
des anciens ministres du gouvernement
socialiste michel baroin ancien grand
maître du grand orient a eu des obsèques
religieuses franc maçon et chrétiens
pratiquants se côtoyaient en cette
église saint françois de sales dans le
17e arrondissement à paris
michel baroin avait tenu être enterré
religieusement
c'était la première fois depuis plus de
120 ans qu'un grand maître maçonnique
avait des obsèques religieuses cela nous
a conduits avec roland sicard frédéric
vasseur a évoqué ce soir les rapports
existant entre l'église et la franc
maçonnerie le tablier pour le travail le
cordon pour l'égalité les gants pour la
orthez des intentions la franc
maçonnerie s'entoure de symboles et de
mystère avec pour objectif perfectionner
l'être humain en france l'obédience la
plus puissante et le grand orient mais à
l'échelle du maçonnisme internationale
il s'agit d'une branche marginal
fortement laïque
ses membres sont pour beaucoup at et les
deux autres grandes obédiences
françaises la grande loge et la grande
loge nationale ne rejette pas
l'existence de dieu à la grande loge
nationale
la croyance dans le grand architecte de
l'univers et même indispensable la franc
maçonnerie traditionnelle est
essentiellement une fraternité
initiatique et l'article 1 de notre
règle et la croyance en dieu obligatoire
donc les francs-maçons font profession
de foi par la croyance en dieu pourtant
les relations entre l'église et la franc
maçonnerie ont toujours été
conflictuelle jusqu'en 1983
l'article 2335 du droit canon frapper
même les maçons d'excommunication cet
article a disparu mais les relations
entre l'église et les loges reste
difficile le nouveau droit canon ne
mentionne plus la franc maçonnerie dans
aucune de ces dispositions
mais elle maintient l'interdiction des
funérailles religieuses
à tout pécheur notoire et comme le
cardinal ratzinger a déclaré qu' on
était pêcheur noir affrontent
appartenait une secte maçonnique dont
les principes sont incompatibles avec la
foi catholique
on pouvait se demander si ça
s'appliquait à michel baroin ou est tout
autre franc basse michel baroin ancien
grand maître du grand orient de france a
pu bénéficié d'obsèques religieuses
parce qu'il s'était rapproché de la
religion
après la mort accidentelle de sa fille
en avril dernier entre l'église et la
franc maçonnerie
les litiges se juge au cas par cas
vous nous pardonnerez une erreur
d'incrustation le premier intervenant
était monsieur yves 13 tournal qui est
député qui est grand maître de la grande
loge nationale française au liban
l'aviation israélienne a repris ses
raids contre des objectifs palestiniens
les israéliens ont attaqué à l'aube les
abords d'un camp de réfugiés près de
saïda les vingt-quatre mille
palestiniens des camps situés au sud de
beyrouth assiégée depuis plus de trois
mois n'ont pas été rabat il ravitaille
et aujourd'hui commentaires gérard inné
du pain seulement du pain c'est le seul
prix de ces femmes palestiniennes qui en
désespoir de cause avait demandé ce
matin aux autorités religieuses sunnites
et au nom de l'islam de les laisser
pénétrer dans le camp de bourj el brh
nier
impuissant et dérisoire aussi ce
fonctionnaire des nations unies qui
attend depuis deux jours avec ses
camions remplis de nourriture
l'autorisation toujours refusée par la
milice amal de ravitailler ce camp alors
qu'à damas nabih berry justifié
aujourd'hui la poursuite du blocus par
la promesse non tenue par les
palestiniens d'évacuer des positions
conquises au sud-liban en novembre
dernier
cela fait maintenant près de trois mois
que ce camp est assiégé nouveau
bombardement de téhéran par l'aviation
irakienne plusieurs maisons auraient été
détruites le bombardement a eu lieu tôt
ce matin ces derniers jours de
nombreuses alertes aériennes ont été
déclenchées dans la capitale iranienne
en urss à moscou une douzaine de réfuges
nick contestataires juillet qui
souhaitent émigrer en israël ont été
interpellés ils manifestaient pour la
quatrième journée consécutive dans le
centre de la capitale soviétique ce sont
quelques unes des images de ces
manifestants que nous avons reçues avant
que des hommes en civil les arrête
une douzaine de personnes arrêtent
en république fédérale allemande la
première expérience de gouvernement
commun avec sociaux-démocrates et
représentant vert vient de s'achever
cela faisait 14 mois que les écologistes
de la région de hesse faisait partie du
gouvernement mais un différend sur
l'exploitation d'une centrale nucléaire
a eu raison de cette cohabitation
les verts se sentent très influent après
leurs bons résultats aux dernières
élections
mais paradoxalement ils sont très
divisés sur la place à tenir au sein du
système parlementaire allemand reportage
de notre envoyé spécial pascal guimier
wiesbaden parlement régional
ici la cohabitation on connaît
écologistes et sociaux démocrates ont
réussi à gouverner ensemble pendant plus
d'un an
un test grandeur nature de ce que
pourrait être un gouvernement de
coalition de gauche à l'échelon fédéral
mais un mariage de raison divorce
retentissant rupture pour cause de
nucléaire
derrière cet échec celui de l'ale droite
des verts sont chefs de file ne regrette
rien il fallait tenter l'expérience
affirme-t-il car rester dans une
opposition systématique ne mène nulle
part
allianz ou repli sur soi le dernier
congrès n'a pas voulu trancher
aujourd'hui avec plus de 8 % d'électeurs
les verts ne peuvent plus rester dans le
vague
à l'heure actuelle le rapport de force
par est en faveur de la ligne dure pour
ses gardiens du temple
un bon tiers du parti toute alliance est
un piège pas question de s'associer au
spd sans de sérieuses garanties
je n'ai rien contre les coalition avec
le spd même au niveau fédéral mais à
condition que ce parti respecte nos
idées notamment contre le nucléaire bien
sûr à l'opposé les réalistes comme on
les appelle ici reste tout aussi ferme
sur les principes mais la nuance est de
taille eux restent ouverts à toutes les
propositions en créer un autre parti et
en entrant au parlement nous sommes
devenus un élément du système il faut en
tirer toutes les conséquences
divergences tactiques en fait crise de
croissance pour un parti jeune entré
comme par effraction dans la
politique allemande il ya tout juste
quatre ans une crise qui fait déjà des
heureux
les partis conservateurs assuré de tirer
les marrons du feu lors des prochaines
élections régionales
il y a un peu plus de deux mois près de
montélimar sur l'autoroute du sud ont
retrouvé le cadavre d'un citoyen
étranger
après de multiples vérifications digne
d'une enquête de romans policiers
on tentait de découvrir l'identité du
mort est ainsi les résidents les mobiles
du crime une instruction était ouverte à
valence peu à peu c'était vers les
milieux syrien que la police dirigeait
ses investigations
ce soir dominique tiercé hervé brusini
révèle quelques-uns des éléments du
mystère du cadavre de l'autoroute a7
l'autoroute a7 une voiture ralentit un
cadavre et jeté hors du véhicule
nous sommes le 4 décembre dernier
lorsque l'homme est retrouvé par deux
agents d'entretien il est mort quatre
balles de 9 mm dans le corps
la gendarmerie de valence commence son
enquête très vite tous les services de
renseignement dst dg ce temps de
dévoiler le secret de l'inconnu de
l'autoroute
il n'a aucun papier d'identité sur lui
les indices sur cet homme bien maigre un
paquet de cigarettes espagnoles un
billet de 500 francs
une carte de téléphone mais surtout
surtout une montre un engin sophistiquée
du même type que celui ci un micro
ordinateur qui permet d'enregistrer
entre autres choses les numéros de
téléphone les gendarmes interrogent à
paris l'importateur de la monte
et pour il avait un problème les numéros
étaient protégées par un code secret un
code d'accès secret donc je veux savoir
si on pouvait forcer ce code
nous avons l excès au japon à casio pour
savoir si cela a été fiable ils nous ont
répondu non il faut essayer les 10000
combinaison quatre numéros de téléphone
ont été décodés l'un d'eux abouti dans
un appartement de cet immeuble
kennedy propriétaire rifaat al assad le
frère du chef de l'état syrien
une piste s'ouvre enfin pour les
enquêteurs l'inconnue serait en réalité
barney abdul razaq alias merzouga infi
rien n'est à damas en 1950 barney raav
étaient recherchés en italie en hollande
pour vol de voiture de luxe un trafic
international qui passe par les grandes
villes européennes à anvers une partie
de la filière a été démantelé
aujourd'hui les véhicules transiterait
par marseille avant d'être revendus au
proche orient
moyennant bien sûr un substantiel
bénéfice autre facette du personnage
barnier raza aurait été l'un des hommes
à tout faire de la famille rifaat
el-assad en france le clan rifaat
représente quelques centaines de
personnes
il possède sa propre radio son nom
radios arabes de paris elle aimait sans
autorisation depuis le 31 décembre
est-ce que vous avez par exemple traiter
le fait divers de montélimar nant
traitons pas le fait divers comme on
l'entend dans certaines rédactions a pas
très longtemps que ce fait divers avait
une consonance entre guillemets
politique il n'est plus pour moi a fait
divers il est un acte politique et je ne
bats pour le risque et non plus deux
d'une plainte en diffamation à valence
un magistrat été saisie du dossier
il lui reste encore à percer le
principal mystère de la sphère de
l'autoroute
le mobile du crime
la chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation a annulé pour des raisons de
procédure toute l'instruction pour
crimes contre l'humanité menée contre
monsieur maurice papon toutes les
inculpations prononcées depuis le 5
janvier 83 sont ainsi devenus sans
fondement
dix-huit personnes ont été interpellées
et placées en garde à vue à antibes dans
le cadre d'une enquête concernant un
trafic d'antiquités ce serait l'aspect
français de ce trafic européen de
meubles et d'oeuvres d'art estimées
environ 10 milliards de centimes à
partir de demain et pour quatre
représentations au palais des sports de
paris le ballet national de marseille
dirigée par roland petit propose ma
pavlova cet albanais en hommage à la
danseuse la pavlova le rôle est
interprété par dominique qu'elle fournit
qui a reçu récemment le grand prix
national de la danse tout le sujet est
bâti autour de dominique qu'elle fournit
reportage grégoire jean vila l'acalf
unis on dit d'elle qu'elle est la
meilleure danseuse française
d'aujourd'hui donc tout désigné pour
incarner le plus grand mythe de la danse
la pavlova la pavlova c'était au début
du siècle étoile des ballets russes de
diaghilev
elle a fait frémir toutes les capitales
avec son inoubliable mort du cygne
gisèle et la sylphide
la performance est une conscience et
d'avoir l'air de faire les choses
facilement
je crois que c'est plutôt sain la
performance et de lait chaque patte de
droite est quand même différent et comme
tout s'enchaîne très vite et qui est des
changements de costumes très très rapide
il ya un peu ce problème aussi de
d'arriver en scène encore essoufflé du
morceau d'avant et de quand même essayer
d'interpréter d'avoir une autre
inspiration à chaque fois
où j'avais envie de lui faire un ballet
de répertoire contemporain
c'est à dire que dans ce ballet elle
apparaît plusieurs fois dans des dans
des rôles disons traditionnel mais que
j'ai interprétés différemment pour elle
dans un coin de la loge mathieu deux ans
et demi le fils de dominique qu'elle
fournit prend des forces lui aussi et du
spectacle c'est formidable
en plus d'avoir sans son bébé dans les
bras en scène c'est une récompense
oui
pour le quarté qui s'étaient disputés
aujourd'hui sur l'hippodrome de
vincennes voici le résultat 18 16 11 14
dans l'ordre pour 5 francs cela vous
donne 23 1988 francs 30 18 16 11 14 dans
un ordre différent 1999 francs pour 500
pour le quarté et puis pour la météo ou
une mauvaise nouvelle qui nous vient de
la réunion une dépression tropicale et
le bilan laurent ce soir est de trois
morts quatre disparus 2800 sinistrés
voilà il s'appelle clotilde à il
s'entoure de vent qui souffle entre cent
soixante dix voire 180 km/heure il a
déjà tué six personnes au moins peut
être cet effet plus de 2800 sans abri
pluies diluviennes route emporté ponts
effondrés et plan orsec déclenché
décidément les cyclones n'épargne
vraiment pas l'île de la réunion en fin
d'après midi le centre de la dépression
se situait à 70 km de lille mais il s'en
rapprochait la météo prévoyait une
aggravation pour les heures à venir
le cyclone pourrait frapper l'île de
plein fouet la nuit prochaine les routes
évidemment ont beaucoup souffert des
personnes ont été emportées dans leur
voiture même des voitures très puissante
et les pluies continuent alors en france
c'est évidemment sans atteindre 7,7
violence s'il ya eu aussi des pluies
diluviennes dans le gard
entre autres il est tombé 100 mm d'eau
en 24 heures c'est un record depuis 50
ans 100 km d'auch qui a fait évidemment
beaucoup augmenter le niveau de l'eau
dans les rivières et créer quelques
dégâts cela dit nous nous sommes entre
deux dépressions alors on va regarder
l'heure va les regarder sur la l'image
satellite la première l et es
aujourd'hui sur sur tout l'est du pays
dues à une dépression centrée sur la
méditerranée autour de laquelle
s'entoure des vents une perturbation
très active mais qu'il a heureusement
s'éloigner vers l'est c'est déjà ça et
puis on a livré une autre très loin là
sur l'atlantique enfin très loin à 500
kilomètres mais elle se rapproche assez
vite et elle va venir demain matin léché
tout on écoute de l'atlantique c'est la
situation que l'on retrouve évidemment
sur la carte du temps prévu pour demain
avec sur l'extrême est du pays les
résidus de cette perturbation quelques
pluies quelques neige encore au dessus
de 15 100 m
quelques orages en corse mais des nuages
qui heureusement vont s'éloigner sur la
majeure partie du pays et pendant la
plus grande partie de la journée
un ciel plutôt ensoleillé quelques
brumes le matin mais des éclaircies qui
se développeront et puis des vents du
nord qui se
qui augmenteront un petit peu qu'ils se
renforçant dans la vallée du rhône
plus à l'ouest c'est à dire de la
bretagne à l'aquitaine sur toutes les
côtes de l'atlantique
arrivée d'une nouvelle perturbation
arrivée de nouvelles pluies arrivées de
nouveaux nuages est arrivé de gens qui
eux aussi se renforceront les
températures sont à peu près
stationnaire par rapport à celle
d'aujourd'hui peut être en légère baisse
7,8 degrés dans le nord-est du pays 7
degrés apparaît à paris lui 10 degrés
dans le nord ouest un beau triplé de 9°
du massi de lyon aa de lyon à limoges
dans le massif central et puis une
moyenne de 13 degrés sur toutes les
côtes de la méditerranée avec un petit
14 degrés à biarritz demain sera le
vendredi 13 février dans du xiii oui
vendu 13 février
il paraît le soleil se lèvera à 8h05 se
couchera à 18h06 trois minutes de soleil
en plus et nous fêterons les béatrice
merci laurent le prochain rendez-vous de
la rédaction d'antenne 2 ce sera en
direct de monte carlo à 22h pour le
magazine présenté par daniel bilalian
daniel bilalian vous proposera une
sélection des meilleurs reportages des
télévisions du monde du monde entier
sélection donc dans le magazine à partir
de 22h et puis dans le dernier journal
de la rédaction 23h qu'un dernier
journal présenté par hervé claude nous
aurons comme invité le grand maître du
grand orient de france monsieur roger
leray en reparlera de la franc
maçonnerie à demain 20h bonsoir
et